September is National Suicide Prevention
month and today is the start of Suicide
Prevention Week here in Nevada local
non-profit Mingo Health Solutions offers
Mental Health Services for those in our
community officials share some ways that
you can help those in your life who may
be struggling with mental health
you don't have to be alone we were not
meant to be alone you are not alone and
help is here from people who really care
if someone shares with you I'm feeling
really like hopeless or or I I thought
about you know killing myself or thought
about hurting myself them being there
for them and saying well let's talk
about it let me get you some support
in Nevada there were 603 deaths from
suicide in 2020 988 is the new National
Suicide and crisis hotline the new
three-digit Lifeline is expected to
serve 7.6 million Americans
and tonight the High Roller at the link
Promenade and Eiffel Tower at Paris will
shine purple and turquoise to Mark the
start of National Suicide Prevention
Week this is all in an effort to
remember the lives lost to suicide and
remind those suffering they are not
alone